la sociologie c'est moi dit Bourdieu
dans les années 1970 il dit à un
journaliste 20 ans plus tard maintenant
en France il n'y a plus d'intellectuel à
ma hauteur je suis tout seul dans ma
catégorie les autres sont morts les
seuls avec lesquels j'ai envie de
rivaliser maintenant ce sont les grands
patrons mais un jour un auditeur
l'interpelle lors d'une conférence
Bourdieu n'est pas
[Musique]
Dieu nous avons peu de recul car
Bourdieu est décédé il y a seulement 20
ans mais nous pouvons le voir comme le
dernier maître à pensé de la gauche
française le dernier grand penseur
français et peut-être même le dernier
grand penseur tout court sur le thème de
l'inégalité dans la lignée de Rousseau
et de Marx Bourdieu a également joué un
rôle majeur dans la mise en avant de la
sociologie longtemps resté dans l'ombre
de la philosophie après ses idées ne
sont pas forcément nouvelles et son
style est complexe mais Bourdieu a eu et
a toujours une énorme influence
intellectuelle il a changé la vision du
monde de beaucoup de gens comment est-ce
qu'il a réussi ce tour de force je vais
vous raconter 10 anecdotes
particulièrement révélatrices vous allez
voir que Bourdieu est un homme
exceptionnel après certaines de mes
anecdotes sont dérangeantes Bourdieu le
défenseur des faibles n'est pas un
sain nous sommes en 1948 Pierre Bourdieu
entre en prépa littéraire au prestigieux
lycée Louis legand à Paris une des
choses les plus pénibles pour lui c'est
de corriger son accent et oui il vient
d'un village dubéarne une région
historique du Sud-Ouest de la France
chez lui on ne parle pas le français
mais la langue locale le béarnet donc
Bourdieu n'est pas du tout un rejeton
des élites parisiennes ni même un
bourgeois il est un bon exemple
d'ascension sociale par l'école son père
est un postier qui a lui arrêté l'école
à 14 ans sa mère femme au foyer a arrêté
l'école à 16 ans après la famille de
Bourdieu n'est pas aussi modeste qu'il
le laisse parfois entendre à l'époque
postier le métier du père n'est certes
pas la position la plus prestigieuse
mais un postier gagne aussi bien sinon
mieux sa vie qu'un institut tuteur le
père de Bourdieu jouit également d'un
logement de fonction quant à sa mère
elle vient d'une bonne famille elle a
hérité de la maison de telle sorte que
les bourdieux sont propriétaire par
héritage bref on est loin de la misère
mais c'est vrai qu'en terme de capital
culturel Bourdieu n'a pas tiré les
bonnes cartes s'ils ne sont pas bac plus
10 ses parents ne l'empêchent pas pour
autant de faire des études ils
l'inscrivent en internat au lycée ses
résultats y attirent l'attention du
proviseur lui-même barnis et ancien
normalien ainsi que du recteur
d'académie ils envoient leur pépit en
prépa littéraire à Louis legand la
meilleure de
Paris Bourdieu réussit du premier coup
le concours de la prestigieuse école
normale supérieure il y entre en 1951 à
cette époque il y a deux stars pour les
élèves de l'école sur le plan de la
pensée ils admirent Maurice Merl Ponti
le philosophe de référence sur le thème
de la perception mais sur le plan du
rayonnement intellectuel la star c'est
bien sûr Sartre les nouveaux normaliens
vont rendre visite au chef de fil de
l'existentialisme Bourdieu lui évite
cette cérémonie c'est pour les petits
cons ditil je suis un produit de l'école
normale qui a trahi l'École Normale
écrira-t-il dans réponse Bourdieu est
donc un renégat de l'élite académique
française d'un côté son parcours fait de
lui un pur produit de l'excellence
académique à la française il a toujours
été un bûcheur et il a toujours eu de
très bons résultats scolaires mais de
l'autre côté il a un regard critique sur
le système qu'il a produit contrairement
à d'autres normaliens Pompidou ou Raymon
hararon par exemple il ne voit pas
l'École normale supérieure comme un
sanctuaire de
génie
au milieu de la vingtaine Bourdieu est
prof de philo au lycée de moulin une
ville du centre de la France de retour à
Paris il loge chez les parents d'un ami
de l'École normale supérieure le père de
cet ami a une énorme bibliothèque c'est
une véritable mine d'or pour Bourdieu il
y passe la nuit à dévorer les livres une
raison de la grande culture de Bourdieu
c'est qu'il est insomniaque si on ne
dort pas on a beaucoup plus de temps
pour lire donc depuis l'adolescence
Bourdieu met à profit les heures de la
nuit pour lire tout ce qui l'intéresse
et puis pour travailler ça sera comme ça
toute sa VI vie lorsqu'il aura une
équipe d'assistants il n'hésitera pas à
les déranger la nuit Luc boltanssk qui
est le co-auteur d'une analyse de
référence sur le capitalisme néolibéral
de la fin du 20e siècle le nouvel esprit
du capitalisme Luc boltansski
travaillait avec Bourdieu dans les
années 1960 et il lui reprochait ses
coups de téléphone nocturnne qui ne
manquaient pas de le
réveiller moulin la petite ville où
Bourdieu enseigne offre peu de
distraction il y a quand même une
librairie Bourdieu y achète le Manifeste
du parti communiste de et Engels et le
libraire le dénonce au proviseur du
lycée c'est que Bourdieu est un prof
original qui inquiète un peu comme
Sartre avant lui il enseigne avec sa
propre méthode il veut ouvrir à l'esprit
de ses élèves il parle sans notes il
donne des exemples intéressants issus de
la poésie de la peinture de la musique
ou de l'expérience quotidienne il
continue à parler avec les élèves en
dehors de la salle de classe un sandwich
à la main il se charge même de
l'éducation musicale de deux fils de
paysans prolétaires qui ne connaissent
de musique que l'accordéon des fêtes
populaires il les invite chez chez lui
et leur fait écouter de la musique
classique il intéresse également sa
classe à l'actualité en abonnant le
lycée à un hebdomadaire après Bourdieu
ne se contente pas de transmettre du
savoir il se méfie même de l'érudition
il comprend que ce n'est pas en se
bourrant la tête de connaissance que les
élèves feront des progrès en
dissertation mais qu'ils ont intérêt à
améliorer leur style donc il les
encourage à écrire un paragraphe par
jour et il leur corrige c'est
pragmatique pour écrire une bonne
dissertation il faut s'entraîner à
écrire bordieu avait compris ça il y a
70 ans mais la plupart des profs actuels
n'ont toujours pas compris le fait que
Bourdieu soit un bel homme au sourire
ravageur ça lui facilite la tâche il est
charismatique il attire l'attention au
lycée et plus tard à l'université les
étudiants sont sensibles à son
charme nous sommes en 1997 Bourdieu a 67
ans il écrit au Premier ministre Lionel
jespin pour lui demander quoi de
protéger un homme qu' l' a connu à
Moulin le dentiste des pauvres Bernard
Jolt réveillé par mai 68 ce dentiste
décide de fournir des soins dentaires de
qualité aux gens qui n'en ont pas les
moyens ils se mettent alors à dos
l'ordre des chirurgiens dentistes et
l'administration qui lui interdisent
d'exercer alors même qu'il est malade
Bourdieu remue ciel et terre pour venir
en aide aux dentistes des pauvres cette
anecdote illustre la sympathie spontanée
de Bourdieu pour les dominé il est très
sensible à leur aliénation pour parler
comme un marxiste et il ne s'agit pas
simplement de sentiments et de paroles
contrairement à beaucoup de partisans
d'une plus grande justice sociale
Bourdieu agit concrètement il intervient
pour améliorer le sort des dominés il n
pas non plus attendu d'être célèbre pour
le faire à l' ns par exemple il prête
une machine à écrire à une femme de
ménage désireuse d'apprendre la dacyo
bien sûr c'est pas la révolution mais
c'est d'une générosité rare ce n'est pas
pour mettre en application une théorie
que Bourdieu aide les gens des classes
inférieures c'est parce qu'il en ressent
intérieurement le besoin il se veut le
défenseur des faibles face aux forts il
est généreux avec les faibles et dur
avec les forts c'est probablement de son
père postier syndicaliste dans un
village du barn que Bourdieu a hérité sa
sensibil ité sociale pardon pour
l'interruption mais j'ai une question à
vous poser vous croyez vraiment que les
gens ont lu tous les livres dont ils
parlent bien sûr que non sinon on ne
pourrait pas parler de grand-chose et
oui il y a 24 heur dans une journée et
il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le
chien donc le secret de la culture
générale ce n'est pas de lire des livres
c'est quoi alors en fait il n'y a pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq les étudiants
et les personnes les plus cultivées les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets vous savez vous avez lu
Renant comme moi mais il se garde bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'ils appliquent les cinq
secrets ils comprennent toutes les
références des personnes cultivées ils
savent s'exprimer avec profondeur sur
n'importe quel sujet ils brillent par
leur culture dans les conversations et
dans les débats et ils ont le recul
nécessaire pour faire preuve d'esprit
critique ça vous intéresse et bien je
vous révèle les cinq secrets et je vous
ai explique comment les appliquer dès
aujourd'hui pour vous cultiver 10 fois
plus rapidement sans vous prendre la
tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit sur celui qui est dans la
description de la vidéo c'est l'histoire
de 10 secondes donc faites-le maintenant
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier
secret qui vous attendra bien au chaud
dans votre boîte mail après avoir
regardé cette vidéo voilà voilà je vous
ai dit ce que je voulais vous dire bonne
vidéo
nous sommes à la fin des années 1950 en
Algérie Bourdieu se rend avec une équipe
d'assistants dans des lieux acquis à la
rébellion algérienne ils s'entretiennent
avec les habitants ces études
s'effectuent en temps de guerre et même
de guerilla avec embuscade suspicion
quand personne ne sait trop de quelqu'un
et l'autre et puis Bourdieu agit sous
l'égide du gouvernement français il a
été missionné pour mener des enquêtes de
sociologie c'est en Algérie que Bourdieu
devient sociologue alors qu'il est un
brillant agrégé de philosophie et que
c'est la discipline reine des années S
Bourdieu se convertit entre guillemets à
la sociologie sa conversion commence à
la fin de ses obligations militaires en
Algérie démobilisé en 1957 il commence à
enseigner la sociologie à l'université
d'Alger l'année suivante et alors à la
demande du gouvernement il effectue ses
premières enquêtes de sociologues il
collecte ses renseignements sur le
terrain toute la matière qu'il accumule
au fil de ces enquêtes fait de lui un
expert de la société algérienne de
l'époque il écrit le que sais-je
intitulé sociologie de l'Algérie qui
sort en 1958 à son retour à à Paris
bourieu n'est plus philosophe il est
sociologue certains observateurs sont
très inquiets lors de Mai 68 Raymond
Aaron craint une véritable révolution et
il cherche des coupables il accuse les
héritiers de Bourdieu et Jean-Claude
Passeron d'avoir embrasé les masses
d'étudiants qui font vaciller la société
française or les deux auteurs sont ses
anciens assistants Bourdieu un des
maîtres à pensé de l'extrême gauche a
donc travaillé avec Aaron un des maîtres
à penser des libéraux ils étaient même
amis comme quoi on peut-être amis en
ayant des convictions très différentes
c'est à son retour d'Algérie en 1960 que
Bourdieu devient l'assistant de Raymond
hararon en sociologie à la Sorbonne et
s'ils sont amis c'est notamment parce
qu'Aron est un chef assez cool il laisse
une certaine liberté à Bourdieu et il
lui permet même de s'affirmer comme
chercheur et enseignant sans avoir à
passer de thèse après Bourdieu et Aaron
ont quand même des profils différents
Aaron a un rapport classique au savoir
et il est élitiste Bourdieu lui est
obsédé par l'origine sociale des idées
et il est attiré par les idéol logie de
gauche la rupture intervient en 1968
mais depuis quelques années déjà
Bourdieu fait équipe avec celui qui lui
a succédé en tant qu'assistant auprès
d'Aron Jean-Claude Passeron lui aussi
normalien il coécrivent deux des livres
les plus célèbres de Bourdieu les
héritiers dont araron pense que c'est le
livre de chevet des étudiants de Mai 68
et la
reproduction Luk boltansky qui a été
dans les années 60 un des premiers
fidèles de Bourdieu raconte ce que
c'était que de travailler avec lui
c'était une vie en groupe avec ses côtés
agréables et aussi ses contraintte cette
espèce de vie collective qu'ont les
adolescents mais c'était
intellectuellement très excitant ce
témoignage révèle que Bourdieu est un
chef d'équipe un manager intellectuel on
pourrait dire il n'est pas contrairement
à Sartre un écrivain qui travaille seul
à sa table il dirige une voire plusieurs
équipes de chercheurs et d'assistants il
les Orient il les aide et eux
s'impliquent dans la logistique
collective comme souvent avec les grands
noms de la pensée occidentale comme avec
Aristote ou Kees par exemple la
célébrité de l'auteur dissimule un
effort collectif mais Bourdu lui ne
cherche pas à faire illusion au
contraire son mode de fonctionnement est
lié à sa conception de la science il
écrit dans Science de la science et
réflexivité avec son habituel manque de
clarté que la science est un immense
appareil de construction collectif
collectivement utilisé version simple la
science est un travail collectif qui a
une utilité collective Bourdieu n'adhère
pas du tout au modèle individualiste de
l'écrivain qui prédomine encore dans les
sciences humaines lui croit en ce qu'il
appelle l'intellectuel
collectif donc Bourdieu est bien plus un
manager qu'un écrivain solitaire alors
c'est quoi son style de management et
bien disons qu'il est exigeant
travailler pour Bourdieu c'est sacrifier
ses nuits pour Charbonnet mais il n'y a
pas que ça le journal Libération dit à
propos des équipes de Bourdieu c'est
l'Albanie l'accusation est lourde parce
que l'Albanie est la dictature la plus
sévère de la seconde partie du 20e
siècle en Europe et puis le pays est
isolé du reste du monde mais la
comparaison qui revient le plus souvent
notamment de la part des universitaires
qui ont fait l'expérience de travailler
avec Bourdieu c'est qu'il est un chef de
se voici par exemple ce que dit Raymond
Aaron à propos de son ancien assistant
un chef de secte sûr de soi et
dominateur expert aux intrigues
universitaires impitoyables à ceux qui
pourrai lui faire ombrage attendez Aaron
il n'a pas fait partie des équipes de
Bourdieu lui non mais sa fille oui
Dominique Schnapper la fille d'Aron a
travaillé plusieurs années auprès de
Bourdieu dans les années 1960 puis
dégoûté par le fonctionnement sectaire
du Centre de sociologie de Bourdieu elle
l'a quitté et elle n'a pas été la seule
comme je l'ai dit Luc boltansski était
l'un des premiers F fidèle de Bourdieu
dans les années 60 et parmi les plus
proches mais il a été un des premiers à
partir en claquant bruyamment la porte
il remettra carrément en cause les bases
de la pensée sociologique de Bourdieu le
problème du management de Bourdieu c'est
qu'il forme ses équipes sur une intense
fusion intellectuelle et affective
autrement dit il veut diriger des gens
qui pensent comme lui et qu' l'
aiment fin 1980 Bourdieu est sur le
point d'être élu professeur au Collège
de France la prestigieuse institution
académique qui regroupe les meilleurs
experts de différents domaine il est
donc sur le point d'atteindre l'une des
plus hautes distinctions de
l'enseignement supérieur français mais
cela ne le rend pas frileux pour autant
car au même moment l'humoriste Coluche
déclare sa candidature à l'élection
présidentielle de 1981 là il ne s'agit
pas d'idée politiqu controversé Coluche
remet carrément en cause le monopole des
professionnels de la politique sur le
système français et Bourdieu soutient la
candidature de Coluche c'est sa première
intervention publique spectaculaire elle
illustre son engagement en faveur de
toutes les révoltes des années 1980
jusqu'à sa mort Bourdieu mul multiplie
les interventions il signe des pétitions
participe à des manifestations des
conférences soutient des actions des
grèves des mouvements et des
associations il s'engage notamment
auprès de droit au logement
l'association qui aide les plus démunis
à accéder à un logement décent et auprès
d'attaque l'association qui milite pour
réduire l'influence des marchés
financiers sur la marche du monde
Bourdieu est particulièrement populaire
dans les milieux altermondialistes au
sommet altermondialiste de Davos de 2001
qui sert de contre somommet au fameux
sommet annuel de Davos le sommet des
puissants de la planète les
organisateurs du sommet altermondialiste
de 2001 diffusent une vidéo de Bourdieu
dans laquelle il défend la nécessité de
ne pas se limiter à la fiscalité pour
combattre le néolibéralisme lui qui
critiquait Sartre il est devenu un
intellectuel médiatique le plus célèbre
des années 1990 d'ailleurs les
journalistes voient en Bourdieu le
successeur de Sartre et daron peut-être
même fut-il le dernier d'une lignée un
article du Monde de fin 2006 s'inquiète
Sartre et Bourdieu disparu s'en est
peut-être fini du penseur engagé à la
France
française si vous aimez l'esprit de
cette vidéo à savoir découvrir des
choses intéressantes en allant à
l'essentiel et sans se prendre la tête
alors vous aimerez probablement mon
programme Culture Express c'est un
programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivé en
seulement quelques mois il couvre tous
les domaines de la culture générale vous
maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l'histoire de
l'humanité sur l'histoire de France en
économie en scienceces politique en
psychologie en sciences en littérature
en art en religion et en philosophie
vous ne surez plus jamais à cours de
choses à dire et vous gagnerez la
confiance nécessaire pour briller en
toutes circonstances vous pouvez en
savoir plus en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche en haut à droite ou bien sur
celui qui est dans la description ou
bien encore en tapant directement
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran dans
la barre de recherche mais je pense que
la meilleure façon de vous donner une
idée du programme et d'écouter ce que
les membres ont à en dire Valentine qui
reconnaît l'énorme quantité de travail
que ce programme a représenté pour moi
dit je cite que c'est une véritable mine
d'or l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliqué concentré il
n'y a plus qu'à recopier et à apprendre
ce travail est vraiment formidable et
passionnant Maxence m'écrit directement
dans les commentaires en dessous d'une
vidéo du programme la formation est
vraiment remarquable j'étais un peu
dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas c'est un vrai
travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui est une mémoire essentiellement
auditive le choix des thèmes et des
chapitres est pertinent et je trouve que
tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite à la fois précis mais sans
fioriture vincent lui fait carrément ma
pub j'ai d'ailleurs recommandé votre
formation à ma sœur qui travaille comm
diplomate la semaine dernière elle a
déjà eu l'occasion de mettre à profit
dans ses discussions les connaissances
que vous avez diffusé vous verrez
d'autres témoignages comme ceci dans les
commentaires si vous rejoignez le
programme et si vous vous inscrivez vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultat une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme
je vous rembourserai intégralement si
vous estimez que vous n'avez pas acquis
une solide culture générale si vous
voulez en savoir plus cliquez sur le
lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite ou
bien sur celui qui est dans la
description ou bien encore taper
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche plus
de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti de ce
programme et je seraai ravi qu'il en
soit de même pour vous dans tous les cas
j'espère que la vidéo vous a plu je suis
romain et vous vous étiez sur 1id de
culture générale rappelez-vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur de
la
[Musique]
pensée